et pour parler de ce désaccord entre
paris et londres nous sommes avec michel
scarbonchi consultant international et
ancien député européen bonjour et merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation sur rt
france alors on le sent bien
l'apaisement n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
les relations entre la france et le
royaume uni qui devrait même se
compliquer c'est le dossier arrive
devant la justice européenne
écoutez nous sommes victimes d'une
opération de politique intérieure
britannique
nous avons un premier ministre monsieur
bourrine johnson qui est en chute libre
dans les sondages qui a de gros
problèmes suite à la crise sanitaire et
suite aux briques site et à ses
conséquences économiques dramatiques en
la grande bretagne et qui donc profite
de la guerre de la pêche aux masques et
face à son opinion publique
toutes ces carences dans la gestion du
pays voilà de quoi nous sommes victimes
vous rendez compte que nous parlons de
94 licence qui devraient être attribués
à des pêcheurs français mille quatre
l'ont été et maintenant nous avons un
contentieux sur 94 licence qui devrait
nous est normalement attribués en tout
cas nos pêcheurs fait la commissaire
européen
madame skin vis us a eu raison de mettre
une date limite à cette parodie de
négociation
entre les deux pays à cause des
britanniques et donc la date finale est
aujourd'hui s'il n'y a pas d'accord
aujourd'hui nous irons contentieux en
justice et la grande bretagne sera
condamné voilà mais ça permet aux
populistes boing boing johnson de
masquer les carences de sa gestion
économique à travers ce litige ridicule
sur la pêche entre la france et la
grande bretagne
alors hier soir le porte parole de boris
johnson a déclaré que l'on n'avait
jamais fixé de date butoir vous le venez
de le dire c'est la date a été fixée par
la commission européenne ce que
concrètement le royaume uni
est il en mesure et surtout en droit de
contester à cette date non il ne peut
pas dans les accords prévus par le brr
excite normalement les pêcheurs français
ayant justifié de la façon dont il pêché
dans les eaux britanniques entre 2012 et
2016 et 2017 et 2019 doivent recevoir
leur autorisation s'ils ne reçoivent pas
la grande bretagne sera condamné en
justice c'est évident et devra payer et
dédommager les pêcheurs français
voilà à quoi la grande-bretagne s'expose
dans ce litige ce contentieux que je
rappelle encore complètement ridicule
quand on connaît les problèmes auxquels
sont confrontés aujourd'hui la grande
bretagne du set des carences de son
économie face à la sortie du bric ci
qu'elle est incapable de juguler de
traiter correctement et on peut que
s'inquiéter vous savez que la grande
bretagne du fait du brics il doit des
milliards d'euros à l'union européenne
entend voit le litige que nous avons sur
la pêche on ne peut que s'inquiéter sur
la capacité de la grande bretagne à
rembourser l'argent qu'elle doit à
l'union européenne et ça c'est pour le
futur
qui viennent à ce qui m'attend
pratiquement plus de onze mois que les
négociations sont en cours entre londres
et paris on sent bien que le dossier va
bientôt passer devant la justice alors
si j'avais la décision rendue n'est pas
accepté par les britanniques est ce
qu'ils peuvent faire appel
ils pourront toujours faire appel
faisant confiance à monsieur boris
johnson pour faire durer l'affairé en
justice vous savez à l'époque de winston
churchill la parole de la grande
bretagne avait du sens et une grande
valeur nous constatons qu aujourd'hui la
parole des britanniques n'a plus aucune
valeur sur le sur le continent européen
on avait vérifié avec le bric site un il
faut se rappeler les mensonges énormes
de monsieur boris johnson on justifie la
sortie de la grande-bretagne de l'union
européenne et donc nous sommes face à un
homme qui est un trompe européen 30
britannique et qui n'a aucune aucun
respect pour les règles internationales
aucun respect pour les traiter
aucun respect pour la parole donnée les
engagements pris voilà à quoi nous
sommes confrontés
mais il faut faire avec
vous avez parlé du nombre de licences de
pêche concrètement quels sont les laits
les conséquences justement pour les
pêcheurs français français aujourd'hui
d'être bloqué de ne pas pouvoir accéder
aux eaux britanniques
cela met en danger leur entreprise 1 94
entreprises françaises sont concernées
par ces licences et donc il faudra
prévoir je crois que ça a été fait déjà
par madame annick girardin la ministre
elle a prévu une enveloppe de 60
millions d'euros je crois ont indemnisé
nos pêcheurs mais indemnisés nos
pêcheurs cela veut dire que nous mettons
fin à leur exploitation quelque part
donc ce sont des entreprises qu'on est
obligé de fermer à cause du comportement
d'un premier ministre britannique
irresponsable
merci beaucoup en tout cas michel par
ascaron chez d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce matin vous êtes consultant
international et ancien député rpr merci